are you guys going to collaborate for
the soundtrack on this or whatever yes
yes
yeah what are we going to do rap and tap
rapping oh cool
that would be hip hey there's harry hey
how you doing
security security
can i tell the fans something what this
guy is this guy is all right
really the the image that you have of
him is all right because
you you're a good girl thanks man
serious it's a great honor to be working
with you
and we're having a great time
holy god and we're having a lot of fun
this is streaks and tips what is what is
the streaks into oh no this
is temporary highlining colors exactly
look at you ship all banged up who's the
man
huh who's the man they come down and
mean you know they're not
see if they came down you know because
we would share
you know humans would share you know we
got some room they could have like
idaho or something like that we they
could have it you know nobody wants to
to be there anyway they could have it
you know but no they want to act mean
you got gotta come down here with an
attitude hacking all big and bad
and what the hell is that smell
i could have been at a barbecue
that's where i uh shoot the alien down
and all that and drag them through the
desert
it's like a salt desert it's like one of
the most bizarre
um attractions of nature you will ever
see you can actually see
far enough that you can see the
curvature of the earth
that's cool right that's real cool you
know myself and jeff goldblum
you know we're forced you know to give
them a taste of their own medicine it's
like
how they gonna fight us with our own
ship that's not fair
you think they have any clue what's
about to happen to them uh-huh not a
chance in hell
i just think that is it it would be
arrogant of us to think that
humankind is the only kind that exists
in the entire universe
you know i mean how is that possible
but i'm like a conspiracy junkie though
so i believe all that stuff
can it really be
do you think about that stuff you do
think about it right i do i think about
it all the time
who knows
welcome to earth oh yeah arnold
schwarzenegger
i've been trying to gun him up a little
bit you got to gut him up a little bit
you know you got to be an action hero
you got to have your guns right you know
you can't
you can't let your gun slip off you know
but no
none of that now there'll be none of
that
elvis has left the building oh thank you
very much
oh i love you that looks like a marine
can you sort of have it down hold on
let's see
that was really that was that was hard
that was that was that was tough though
right
you know that's it because you know how
hard you salute shows how much respect
you have for the person at your school
that was right you know that was guys
because i have a lot of respect for john
and america
[Music]
that's what i call a close encounter